كل شخص هنا يعلم لمن سيصوت ولكن لمن ستصوت
الورقه الحائره الورقه الحائره المتمثله
في تحالف الاجداد خاصه بعد تفككه ودعم
مرشح التحالف سيران
ودعم رئيس حزب النصر وهو العمود الفقري
لتحالف اجداد لمرشح المعارضه كلجدار اوغلو
يذكر ان تحالف الاجداد حصل على 5.17 في
الانتخابات ووقته اطلق الاعلام عليه سنان
اوغان صانع الرؤساء هذه ورقه من الاوراق
الحائره ولكن هناك ورقه اخرى ايضا متماثله
في ثمانيه ملايين صوت لم يصوتوا في الجوله
الاولى واذا ما كانوا سيصوتون في هذه
الجوله الثانيه هناك ايضا ورقه حائره ربما
متمثله في الشباب خاصه الذين اتموا بين
الجوله الاولى والجوله الثانيه 18 عاما
ومتحمسون للتصويت ولكن لمن سيصوتون انا
ضحى الزه يري معكم من اسطنبول لتغطيه
الجوله الثانيه والحاسمه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه